[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud L proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony michles podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the free freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty you [__] eating [__] ah the
smell of freedom of speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
booger sugar
[Music]
junor against daddy
today how many times does he take the
fifth in open court he's not going to be
the only one Eric and ianka in the days
to come will be testifying also against
Donald Trump because that's what you do
in a trial that he's already been found
guilty of
fraud that's right it's a bench trial
and the judge has already decided that
Donald Trump has committed fraud all
they're trying to figure out is how much
money
now it's not going to be that exciting
because Donald Trump Jr is a fraking
idiot Bonafide I think he's I think he
has paperwork on it to if you want to
know the honest truth I mean there's
plenty of
evidence that he's a bonehead out there
I mean he puts it out on the internet on
his on his podcast where he's triggered
literally he calls his podcast triggered
where he's triggered
by
the libtards or something I don't know
it's it's a weird show every once in a
while we show clips of it but it gets
tiring just to watch him do the bunny
ear rabbit ear quote air quote thing
whatever he does because he just does
this the whole
time and he's got a white powy substance
over his face sometimes but the best
news about this uh testifying against
Donald Trump is that it is enraging
Donald Trump and I have a few videos
that I want to show you today of Donald
Trump I don't know my friend Jeremy
London um retweeted one of these things
and he pointed out something that Jerry
London is an actor you probably know him
from like M rats or this seventh heaven
you know something like that
but the thing is is that like when
you're shooting video when you're not
doing it live like if you're cutting it
to put it out on the internet you got to
chance to I don't know edit it and it
goes back into is this [__] real or
is this AI like he I don't know like
what how am I supposed to know this
stuff at this point like we gotta
question everything we see and I I
question this clip that I'm gonna show
you where Donald Trump basically says
that manga are tyrants people who
support the Maga movement are tyrants
that's what he says now I don't know if
it's a fre lip or if he messed up but
they published
it they published it and we're supposed
to believe that Joe Biden and his team
in the White House are
incompetent he put He put this out on
true social I mean what do you want from
me I didn't I didn't make him do this so
I wonder if there's going to be any gaps
in the courtroom today where where
Donald Trump Jr booger sugar Jr as I
refer to him um you know messes up says
something that he shouldn't say but what
do you think how many times are we are
we going to take like bets on this how
many times that Donald Trump Jr has to
play the fifth now I know I know Eric
was the one that pleed the fifth the
least amount and there's been a lot of
focus on this Gap the uh General
accounting accepted
practices or excuse me journaling
accepted accounting practices um that
Donald Trump Jr learned at the business
school of Wharton's School of Business
right there's a clip I'm going to show
you of that too again you know what's
funny about this trial you know what's
really funny about it like we're not
hearing anything about the like the the
transcripts of the testimony or like any
of that stuff because this is boring
[__] right this is boring stuff this
isn't like the the Trump dumpster fire
that we're so used to that's why when he
walked into the courtroom he does the
dumpster fire thing out in front of the
courtroom because he can't do the
dumpster fire thing in inside the
courtroom he's already been fine $15,000
because he won't shut his [__] trap
and it looks like jkin H he's gonna get
more of a gag order there now what the
punishment is you know I don't know I
don't know I have no idea I I don't
actually think they're gonna put him in
jail at this point for any kind of gag
order or breaking a gag order I don't
think they're going to
why would they I mean they they
absolutely put a January 6 defendant in
jail over a gag order you remember us
reporting this Scott McFarlin was
reporting it from inside the courtroom
there was a scuffle with the January 6
defendant after he was trying to dox or
did dox some of the federal
investigators on his Instagram account
the judge said you can't do that and he
said it's my first amendment
right well that that's not the first
amendment that that sort of speech is
not protected under the you know why
don't we talk about that for a second
because a lot of people get free speech
confused because there's a lot of speech
going around right now there's a lot
there's a lot there was a a a a student
at Cornell arrested for sending death
threats to Jewish students and he's a
he's a student at Cornell federally
charged good good good for those Federal
prosecutors to beat back on this
anti-Semitism and and death threats I
don't care which [__] way it goes I
don't care if you're sending death
threats to Jewish people or Muslims it's
a bunch of [__] we need to grow the
[__] up in this
world that yeah there's people with some
views and especially when their ideology
is shaped by their theology it's going
to get a little weird but that doesn't
mean that they don't have the right to
exist you [__]
Rubes and I'm I've told you that a lot
of these pro- Palestinian protests I
don't agree with every aspect of their
protest I don't agree with every bit of
it but I absolutely believe that is
their [__] right to March it is their
right to call the death an
atrocity I'm not in agreeance that it's
genocide but I it is an
atrocity that is happening in Gaza as
hundreds of innocent people get
killed now I mean again there's a lot of
Truth there that we have to sort through
and there's a lot of context that we
have to sort through but the thing is is
that people are believing a lot of stuff
that is not true some are believing
propaganda from Israel some are
believing propaganda from Hamas the idea
that that Israel had to attack a refugee
camp and kill refugees just to get one
Hamas militant leader I think that's a
little absurd a little
ridiculous uh just this morning the
Egyptian border is starting to to
open and let some of the Palestinians
that are injured uh into Egypt to
receive medical care which thank God for
that Humanity uh as petroleum trucks
drive across the Egyptian border uh into
Gaza now I'm hoping that it's just
petroleum that they're carrying for
humanitarian
Aid because there needs to be
humanitarian in Gaza fast quick and in a
hurry and it ain't just because of Hamas
it's because isra Israel is starting to
flatten parts of it because Hamas is
they operating in a military
operation where they have committed war
crimes in their
country so Israel has the right to
defend itself and it has the right to go
get the people that have committed those
atrocities and hold the accountable the
group that enabled those
atrocities against their civilians all
this stuff is
true but it's again
again we believe we believe what we want
to
believe but we have to get this straight
on the First Amendment here right
because that matters now our first
amendment is different than other Free
Speech laws around the world ours is
very open but it is very
precise on hate speech and it is very
precise on what hate speech and hate
crimes are it's very specific on
it so this idea that we can we can just
let hate crimes and hate speech run a
muck in this country is all [__]
[__] that's not free
speech it's not free speech when you
when you
stab a Muslim child it's not free speech
when beating up Jewish people because
you're an
anti-semite it's not free speech when
you're threatening the lives of people
because of their religion that's not
free
speech you [__]
boneheads I always you know I
continually have to uh beat back on Maga
because these these these online incel
Bros these Elon simps they have no
[__] clue what free free speech is
not a [__] clue they think free
speech is I get to say and do whatever I
want without consequence your speech
always has
consequence
always there is never a time where your
speech does not have consequence
folks trust me as someone who speaks two
hours a day every single weekday into a
microphone my speech has
consequence now yesterday a lot of the
audience disagreed with me heavily of
what I was saying about the conflict in
Gaza they disagreed heavily with me and
this morning I I'm sure that they're
going to agree with me when I say it is
absolutely ridiculous that Israel
flattens a refuge Camp to get one leader
of Hamas seems a little [__] out of
out of
sort and we should we should make sure
we hold them to account to account and
not let them do that anymore
as best we can as our country because
we're not in this conflict I know a lot
of people think that we are but we are
we are there to be the middleman Arbiter
here and and it is working this morning
across the Egyptian
border I told you yesterday and I showed
you video yesterday inside a a senate
Appropriations Committee that was
chaired by Patty Murray that Anthony
blinkin secretary of state was
testifying in against about some of
these issues uh happening in the Middle
East and there were protesters in the
room and Patty Murray paid those
protesters uh the the due respect that
they
needed she let them protest in the way
that they wanted to protest now they're
not allowed to interrupt an official
proceeding that that's something that's
not allowed you just again that isn't
your free speech you don't get to go
into a city council meeting and start
kicking over chairs and yelling and
screaming without being removed that's
not free
speech it's just not you will be
removed you don't get to go to Walmart
and spray paint on the side of their
building [__] Walmart that's not Free
Speech but you can stand out on the
sidewalk on the public sidewalk beyond
their parking lot with a big sign that's
spray painted [__] Walmart that is your
free
speech not every
not everything you say not everything
you do is your right and not only that
again these [__] boneheads don't
understand that there's consequences for
your
speech every single time whether it's a
good consequence or it's a bad
consequence this is how it works
folks it's how it
works I told you it was it's absolutely
laughable hilarious and ridiculous that
Marjorie Taylor green would call Pro
Palestinian protest at the capital and
Insurrection she obviously clearly does
not know what the word Insurrection
means she wants to commit them but she
doesn't want to look it up in the
[__]
dictionary but it's not surprising that
Marjorie Taylor green and her ilk have
no clue how the First Amendment works
and how it's applied here in this
country
look you get to say whatever the hell
you want really honestly in this country
you can say almost anything you want to
say you can and as long as you find a
place that will that will give you an
amplifier a lot of people will hear your
speech sometimes you don't have an
amplifier and no one hears your
speech and generally speaking when no
one hears your speech there aren't too
many
consequences because no one's listening
you're just yelling into the
void but when people hear your speech
there are
always
consequences
always no matter good or bad
consequences whichever you want to you
know categorize them
as if I say something here and it makes
the audience upset I get a lot of a lot
of comment
hell I might get a few haters that that
leave the show that unfollow me I've had
some that unfollow me on patreon and you
know what they send me a message I've
had several of them send me messages
before saying they're leaving for
patreon for this thing that I
said and I I can't begrudge them for
that I don't attack
them I mean it's my speech I get to say
it but there is
consequences and I'm okay with
consequences of speech because I fully
understand that there are consequences
to Speech but a lot of people don't
understand
this now for instance I'm going to show
you a
clip yesterday happened secretary my
orcus of Homeland Security is being
questioned by oh my [__] senator from
the great state of Missouri Josh Holly
who doesn't live in Missouri by the way
Josh Holly didn't do his homework and
his staff didn't do his homework to know
that my
orcus his
family was executed and exterminated in
the Holocaust and his mother was a
Survivor no
clue Josh Holly stepped in a big pile of
[__] and jumped on the rake at the same
time but the back and forth in the
volley back and and forth was over a
post that a DHS employee posted on his
private social media about his
support for
Palestinians and the problem is is that
they used a parachuter with a
Palestinian flag which is a symbol of
Hamas
folks that's how Hamas got into Israel
to commit their
atrocities and their war crimes to
slaughter innocent Israelis
that's how it happened so when you're
when you're posting pictures of a
parachuter with a Palestinian flag
you're Pro Hamas whether you realize it
or not and you're for a terrorist
organization and I believe that people
out there can be Pro
Palestinian and not supporting Hamas at
all those two TRS can exist at the same
time and that person's speech has huge
consequences to post on their Instagram
account to be a DHS employee and be
posting pramas
propaganda on their Instagram account
and that's what
happened and when stuff like that
happens there's consequences of it the
one consequence is that Josh Holly Gets
to bring it up in some [__] Senate
hearing to try to use it against
democracy that's right
your speech your speech has consequences
against democracy why do you think I
call it out when I see
it when people are using their speech in
a way that that undermines the
institution and the foundation of our
liberal Democratic constitutional
republic I call it out I don't give a
[__] who it
is I don't give a [__] I don't care if
it's tyt and Jen gunger I don't give a
[__] if it's Glenn Kush I don't give a
[__] because I'm telling you they're
undermining our institutions of
democracy when they're doing these
things and it may not seem like it now
it may seem like it's protecting it but
in the protection you can undermine the
foundation of what you truly are trying
to
do and
speech is one of the best ways to get
your message out good bad or indifferent
and there are consequences good bad or
indifferent and sometimes there's
short-term consequences but most times
for speech there's long-term con
consequences why do you think we live in
the world that we live today where we
are at the intersection of WrestleMania
and real
life is because we allowed the
buffoon to become
mainstream not just in our ENT tainment
venue oh God Donald Trump is a great
clown isn't he oh my God he's such a
[__] goof and he's easy to goof on
right with the hair and the stupid
[__] suit the long ass tie the dumb
[__] hand movements right stupid
voice the orange [__] painted face
right so easy to goof on so such
entertainment that [__] is but why for
the presidency
why so much so that I'm going to show
you a clip today on Trader TV News
Network where they're making Biden who's
handing out candy for Halloween some
kind of [__] entertainment it's weird
stuff I'm not gonna
lie I'm not gonna lie it's weird stuff I
I I and I've watched people make fun of
trump and goof on Trump when he was
handing out candy uh to Hall to to
Halloween on Halloween to trick- or
treaters the one in particular where he
puts the candy on the kid's
head I mean it's funny it's goof but
really does it speak to anything of how
someone could or can or should be
president no it's really [__]
dumb it's really [__]
dumb that we would use our speech in
that way the same way it's done that we
would use our speech to to point in a
direction that secretaries of state are
going to have unilateral power to strip
away someone's access to the
ballot yes I think that's ridiculous I
think that's dumb speech and I think
it's going to have serious consequences
to come to our democracy it really truly
is when the left is yelling and
screaming when the left is yelling and
screaming about the 14th amendment in
one state and one Secretary State and
this secretary of state folks that's
dangerous [__] to our democ democracy
it's dangerous [__] to the foundation
and the institution of our Republic it
truly is I know you don't think it is
because he's a danger but we we the
people are the government it is us we
are the
Republic it is us who chooses to
represent us under the
Constitution and many facets and forms
in our government rather it be the
president of the United States whether
it be your United States senator now not
it didn't used to be that way I don't
know if you know that we didn't used to
votee for senators rather it's your
Congress
people it's your Governor your State
Attorney General your state senators
your state representatives all the way
down city council County Commission down
to the [__] dog
catcher and when you start undermining
when you start undermining because you
don't like what is happening when you
start undermining our democracy and you
you start using your freedom of speech
to undermine those foundations of
democracy when you start doing that it
has long-terms
effect wild long-terms effects that you
can't
predict and it's best that you stand on
the institutions and the foundations of
democracy as opposed to trying to use
them to your will and to bend them to
your needs and your
wants it's not a good idea to do that
that's what the right wants to do all
the time everywhere that's the one
reason why we're in such [__] shape
right
now why it feels like we can't get the
clowns out of our government why we
can't get people in both parties to want
to
govern because they have used their
speech to undermine our liberal
constitutional Democratic
Republic
over and over and time and time again
Donald Trump does it on a
daily and I'm here to speak out against
fascism and
authoritarianism no matter where it
shall come
from and when someone tells me they want
to use unilateral
power at a state
office to keep someone off the
ballot that we don't know if that is
constitutional or not and I mean it's
being worked out in the courts
folks I I actually don't think it's
gonna
happen I still don't I don't think
there's any Secretary of State that's
willing that to go out on that
limb to stake their entire career their
entire Legacy their entire political
Legacy on rather you can 14th Donald
Trump before he's been convicted of
insurrection
or sedition or conspiracy to obstruct
official proceeding he's
charged he's
charged but is that
enough I don't know why would we ask the
question when we the people can take
care of him that's our freedom of
speech and we should be using our
freedom of speech to hold up the
institutions of democracy to support
those institutions to support that
Foundation
why do you think I back
Israel and why do you think I back the
Palestinian people to have actual real
Liberty not [__] false
Liberty where to to think that Hamas is
their protector [__] that [__] Hamas is
their oppressor
folks it's their
oppressor
so it's time that we all get this free
speech thing
right rather rather we talk
about the 14th Amendment which I was
just speaking about or rather we talk
about this conflict in
Gaza and the history the context and the
and the extemporaneous events
surrounding it and why it is where it is
because again I can sit here and tell
you that my I know for sure that BB
Netanyahu is a right-wing
fascist I also can tell you that Hamas
is a [__] fascist terrorist
organization and I can also tell you
that is Israel has the right to protect
itself it absolutely has the right to
protect
itself
and it has the right to retaliate
against that fascist terrorist
organization that committed war crimes
on their
civilians and I can also tell you that
the Palestinian people deserve to be
free free from oppression no matter
where it comes from free from murder
free from genocide as some people want
to call
it and we can be absolutely clear on
this that Israel should not
have level a refugee camp to get one
Hamas
leader seems a little [__]
ridiculous but I can also tell you in
the same breath that is true that when
Hamas picks their launch sites on
purpose for retaliation to kill
civilians so that they can pump
propaganda into the world it is a real
thing they are choosing to do that
a lot of things can be true all at the
same time and we must use our speech and
we must understand Free
Speech because in today's
world this
microphone this machine kills fascist if
we let
it this machine kills
fascist but it can also promote
fascism so you have to decide where your
speech lies and you have to understand
that there's consequences for every
single part of your speech so don't go
anywhere because I got like an hour and
a half of speech left I really do every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central two full hours
on YouTube twitch and Facebook as they
say on the radio don't touch that dial
we'll be right back 60
Seconds we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy P's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product Parton blanket I've got
you covered paron blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too Hardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast ooh the pardon
blanket well don't you wish or don't you
know that Don Jr and Donald
Trump they wish they had a pardon from
the Civil Trial in war oh
man money money money money money
well if they wouldn't have concentrated
so heavily on money maybe they would be
in better shape I know that we're gonna
get a lot of images here today
um I've already got some images inside
the courtroom that's right and I know
we're going to talk about AI today
because I got a couple images that are
so real uh inside the courtroom right
now and then a video from Donald Trump
that did he really say that did he
really did he understand what he was
saying when he said that is that AI is
it real or is it AI you know I I can't
really tell you're going to have to help
me is
it or is
it but I tell you what is real I tell
you what's real folks your love for the
new merch you saw this design here this
is the one where the new design this
machine kills fascist the Tony Michaels
podcast t merch that's right I'm going
to get this tattooed on my arm it's not
going to be the exact design because the
t-shirt and the tattoo have to be a
little different but it's all going to
be inspired by the same idea where this
microphone kills Fascism and a lot of
people have went and started to order
their tattoo merch and you can get yours
10% off that's right 10% off just go to
the Tony michaels.com let me show you
that here you go to the Tony
michaels.com and you just pan down right
here tattoo merch collection it's all
right there
you can go order your tattoo merch now
it helps support the show and you get a
cool piece of merch here's the one
here's the hoodie with the with it on
the front so you can order a hoodie with
it on the front or a hoodie with it on
the back there's t-shirts there there's
coffee
mugs there's all sorts of great stuff
going on we have some other merch to
announce every even my dog hates dead
Cruz even my dog hates that whose dog
doesn't hate Ted Cruz even Ted Cruz's
dog hates Ted Cruz right am I right I
know I'm right uh if you go to the Tony
michaels.com you just click my dog hates
Ted merch it'll take you right to the
store where you can order the even my
dog hates Ted Cruise we're going to do
more we're g to do cats my cats hate Ted
Cru but here's the thing for the tattoo
merch here's the promo code I want you
to use this week you get 10% off this
tattoo merch if you use the promo code
tattoo10 that's
tattoo1 that's capital t one Z tattoo 10
capital T tattoo1 now if you want 10%
off your even my dog hates Ted Cruz
merch use the promo code podcast that's
all caps that's
podcast use the promo code podcast on
that merch store for 10% off even my dog
hates Ted Cruz merch I have some more
announcements here I want to announce
that we have a book club going that's
right the [__] them fan book Club the
first book is the obstacle is the way by
Ryan holiday the obstacle is the way by
Ryan holiday they're also going to be
listening to Rachel mat's audio book in
groups listening to it and having
discussions as they listen uh so you're
welcome to come join the book club let
me show you how you get to the book club
on the website you just go right on down
to memberships and you see the book club
tab right here now the book club is in
Discord um you don't have to do all the
other stuff in Discord you can can just
go to Discord and join the book club
you'll be able to join in on those
conversations about Rachel mat's
audiobook and also the very first first
book They're reading which is the
obstacle is the way by Ryan holiday so
go check out the book club today it's on
Discord and maybe you'll find some other
stuff you like on Discord we got an
arcade going over there people share
their Foods pictures and their great
pictures that they have and they share
um and they share their mem around it's
a it's a great place to hang out um and
we also have a there where they play
they play movies and group viewing so go
join the book club today on the [__]
F and if you just click the link there
you know what um here's what we should
do um I want to do a little bit of
shooting the [__] um but I want while
we're shooting this [__] I want to show
you some of these images from the
courtroom rat here uh Rat are you are
you are you around rant are you around I
just want to make sure rant's ready with
some of these images that we're getting
from inside the courtroom oh there he is
there there's H here here's rat uh he's
right here ah there he is looks like
he's working on some arcade games here
are you working on games too not just
Imaging oh okay that makes sense that
makes sense so there's rant working on
some arcade
games in the
laboratory and this laboratory just
keeps getting bigger and bigger doesn't
it he's working on some games he's
working on images now here's here's an
image that we have uh from inside the
courtroom looks like um Donald Trump and
Don Jr
testifying uh is it real or is it AI I
don't know I'll ask
[Music]
you it's up to you to decide whether
it's real or say hi this is why you
should question everything now Don Jr
looks a little Hefty in this and it
doesn't look like he's been doing enough
Coke in this one he's doing enough Coke
to you know lose about 50 pounds a week
Donald Trump obviously is uh he's got
the neck Gina thing going in this one it
it's pretty goddamn close isn't it here
let's let's see if we can get another
image uh from the courtroom here's
here's this image uh well you know what
you know what I I misspoke Don Jr looks
but this looks a little too young you
know what I mean this looks like young
Don J junor now but Donald Trump man
it's look how spoton that
is look how spot on that is this is some
scary [__] ain't
it these are produced just within a
matter of
minutes yeah if you look at his hand and
you count the fingers one two three four
five six he's got five fingers in a
thumb I don't know what the hell you
gonna do everyone's saying it's AI of
course it's AI just goofing on these son
[__] I'm just goofing on them uh we
have some more AI images I want to show
you this is one this is one we should
have had yesterday you know it was a
little late but we had it there if you
guys can pick this out this is the box
wine lady from Fox News Janine periro
look
listen I know I know these images are
crazy um but folks they're really
they're really really really really good
now six months from now they're going to
be even
better and a year from now it's going to
be
crazy there's going to be the
capability of like this picture here of
Don Jr and Trump to be manipulated into
a
video very
quickly put it on a newscast give the
newscast voice over have them saying
crazy [__] you know we we watched the
AOC clip the other day of AOC saying
some crazy [__] and you know it was AI I
mean it says fake the nation on the tag
so it obviously was someone you know
trying to trick
us well what if they're not trying to
trick us what if they weren't being
trying to trick us what if they were
trying
to trick their
sheep right I don't know it's completely
possible it's not out of the realm of
possibility that they would use AI in
this way especially in a courtroom to
trick people I mean imagine imagine
today that you see a video clip that
maa's circling
around that basically uh in the clip it
exonerates Donald Trump from this Civil
Trial but it's fake it's not real what
happens when they believe
it I you know I I I don't know I mean
here's a couple Clips here you can tell
me if you think this [__] is real or not
or if it's AI here's um here's this one
here this one is Donald Trump um now
this video is posted from his true
Social account so it looks like it's
real but let's listen let's hear what he
has to say and see if we think it's real
or AI idea they may hate our country and
they may want to see it destroyed but it
may also be the last election we ever
have if this election doesn't work if
this election is rigged and stolen okay
okay stop right there it's that right
there rather this is real or this is AI
this is even if this is AI this is some
projection type AI right I mean this
[__] is basically telling us if
if these tyrants win this next election
if they rig and steal it then it'll be
the last election like yeah that's why
I've been telling everyone we need to
engage in our democracy so this [__] box
doesn't win but yeah keep going there
Grandpa poopy pants if bad things happen
our country will not survive if crooked
Joe and the Democrats get away with
removing my name from the ballot then
there will never be a free election in
America
again so he's talking about the 14th
Amendment right that's what he's talking
about he's talking about this case in
Colorado because the case in Colorado is
the one that's most advanced some of the
other ones have just petered out and
died off right there's several of these
14th Amendment cases and I know some
people were saying Tony it's in the
Constitution it's in the con it is in
the
Constitution it is just because
something is in the Constitution doesn't
know doesn't mean that we know exactly
how it is going to work in real life
folks you understand that right like
just because we apply the Constitution
to Something in theory doesn't mean
that's how it's actually going going to
play out in the courts and in real life
you understand that right you get that
right why do why do you think it's so
[__] gross that they undermined the
Voting Rights Act why do you think it's
so [__] gross that they used our our
process to get rid of roie
Wade which granted
people actual rights and privacy with
their doctor based on oh what's that
document called the
Constitution and it's based on how it's
interpreted
folks I know that's you know
Silly to think that we have to interpret
the constitution based on our laws but
it's a thing that we have to
do and I know even kayin is saying here
and and I'm sure she's a proponent of
this Tony this will ultimately go to
Supreme Court and be decided there yes I
know that and that's the problem with it
that's the trouble that I have with it
you understand that right that's the
trouble that I have with
it because if if the Supreme Court and
the courts make the wrong long-term
decision folks it can undermine our
democracy it can have underpinnings that
we don't even understand in the
moment the same way as we don't
understand this AI stuff we don't get
the long term
consequences of that speech and whose
[__] speech is
it we have to get out of our tunnel
vision the only tunnel vision we should
have is for the institutions and the
foundations of our free
democracy that's it
period I believe that diversity Equity
equality inclusion will lead us to a
greater
Society but the only way to do
that is to make
sure that anything that threatens that
institution does not threaten it and we
don't go down this road of trying trying
to keep Trump off a ballot in C or
Colorado and taking it to the Supreme
Court and then him
winning
yes I know I know you say well there's
no possible way in
that there
is but what if he loses what if he loses
and what if 30 years from now we have
another Tyrant that rises to
power and decides that they're going to
use that
decision to just unilaterally tell the
secretaries of state to use their power
to keep someone off the
ballot because they sent a message out
on the internet that seems like they're
against the government that it would be
in type of insurrection that they would
be in support of it folks I'm telling
you we cannot undermine our
democracy we can't do it not especially
not for this
[__] if we're undermining our
democracy for this [__]
there are long-term consequences just
like putting him in power has long-term
consequences using the weapons of our
constitution to keep him off a ballot
when we are the ones who can
vote now if he's charged with
Insurrection and convicted I'm all for
it they took that county commissioner
what was a guy what the hell was his
name out was was it Nevada or was it New
Mexico that they took this guy out of
his actual position because he was
charged and
convicted as an insurrectionist in
Washington and the federal judge said oh
you're convicted oh you're a county
commissioner H I'm gonna 14th your
ass I think that has Merit it was in New
Mexico yes um what was his name was what
the guy the Cowboys for Trump guy you
know what I'm talking about you know
what I'm talking about guy where's the
cowboy at
[__] big step fan says I agree with ton
surprisingly whoa I would love to Trump
not allowed to run but I don't want the
courts to decide it
exactly
exactly that's exactly the point it's a
great way to put it big Steph it's a
great way to put it is that we I don't
want him on the
ballot coy Griffin is the guy's name yes
that's it Coy Griffin he's an [__] um
I don't want Trump on the ballot but
that's not that's not for the courts to
decide at this point it maybe at some
point it maybe at some
point might be at some point we might
have to because you know this
[__] if he's still eating
cheeseburgers if this guy's still able
to gobble up Big Max in 2028 even if
he's in a prison cell this [__]
is goingon to try to run you know that
right because it's all a big [__]
Griff to him so he's gonna keep the
Griff to keep on Griffin you know what I
mean let's finish up what the poopy
pants pukes up here about Joe Biden is
going to steal the election we will have
become a dictatorship where your
president is chosen for
you or certainly won't have a meaningful
vote and you could say frankly that that
has already
begun H again this is all projection
because this is truly what he wants this
is what he wanted this is what he wanted
in January
6 he wanted to overturn the election the
[__] new wiener of the house said it
he said it the new wiener of the house
[__] said
it it's the election n speaker of the
house he said it in a clip mikro Johnson
the wiener of the house said that if we
could overturn this election and he was
talking about the 2020
election if we could just overturn this
one he was saying it out loud that they
wanted to overturn the election meaning
they knew Trump lost but they wanted to
steal it away from Joe Biden you know
Legally
Legally using the Constitution
legally which is undermining our
institutions of democracy folks so why
would we want to do the same why why
well Tony it says it right there in the
Constitution goddamn it yeah well they
were interpreting the Constitution to
try to steal our government too you get
that right they're still talking about
how the Constitution allows them to
overturn elections why do you think they
thought that they had the right to go to
commit fraud
in fton county and on Georgia for the
fake State electors the same way in
Michigan and probably going to get
charged in Arizona for the [__] maybe
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin folks this
stuff [__] matters at the end of the
day and how we aim our strategic outrage
[__] matters too especially our
narrative and when this guy can get on
the horn and say this stupid
[__] because people in this country
country don't know how to [__] engage
in their democracy and have confidence
because that's really the [__] case
here I have
confidence in the voters I have
confidence I'm optimistic about our
country I know that I'm cautiously
optimistic I know that sounds
weird because I sit here and [__]
give you cathartic outrage every day but
the point is is to get you to go engage
in your
democracy and so many of you do there's
so many people that send me messages
that they're making phone calls that
they're leaving messages with their
Congress people they're sending
emails they're going to go knock doors
they're in they're in postcard campaigns
they're supporting a candidate locally
where they are this is all
engagement
right and we cannot breed
discouragement folks let me tell you
something
about discouragement in this
14th if it comes down to the very last
second we're almost about to win oh
we're going to keep him off the ballot
it's only up to the Supreme Court
Justices to make sure our democracy is
saved to not have Donald Trump on the
ballot and allow secretaries of state to
unilaterally take him off the ballot in
their state and and it comes down to the
very last
second no time to waste the Supreme
Court must make their
decision and their decision will set our
democracy free when they decide to keep
Donald Trump off the
ballot and they decide to keep him on
the
ballot boy won't that just just deflate
the pro-democracy
coalition
won't that just breed discouragement in
this country and the more discouragement
you breed the more disengagement you
breed and when you breed disengagement
folks it is dangerous as
[__] it's the reason why that [__]
eating [__] fool won in
2016 because people were
discouraged so don't be
clamoring to keep Trump off the ballot
being
raged use your cathartic outrage use
your strategic outrage to aim it in a
way that engages
democracy aim it in a way that will
engage the vote that will drive people
to the battlefield of the
ballot that is how you rally our
democracy that is how you rally Liberty
in this country not not not discourage
it with dis disengagement or disengage
it with
discouragement we must get our heads
right folks we can beat this
fool we can beat this fool
easily if we use our energy right and we
use our first amendment
correctly to have the correct
consequence that we are willing to live
with in our democracy because that's
truly what we're
choosing that's truly what we're
choosing and I I'm GNA show
you consequences of free speech here
because I'm about to goof on this some
[__] oh my God just like he cut the
last video they cut this one too this is
a cut he didn't like just you know and I
don't know maybe this is AI [__] I don't
know it could be the last one could
could have been this one could be is
[Music]
it you're going to decide whether it's
real or AI you're the one who asked the
question it I mean look at this look at
this image here I want to show you this
image here again watch watch this image
here this one here it looks so real and
that do that image of him look real I
mean if you cut Don Jr and his
six-fingered hand out of it right that
could be I that could be really close
you would have to question it especially
if his mouth was moving he was talking
with his voice it might you know H we're
not we're months away from this being
absolutely something that could be
real so tell me if you think this is
real listen to what he says listen to
his words it's very important that you
listen to specifically what he says this
is your chance to take a stand against
tyrants that support the one and only
movement that can save our country and
make a America great again wh what what
what what did he say he said support the
movement that's going to make let's
listen again this is your chance to take
a stand against tyrants and support the
one and only movement that can save our
country and make America great again so
the tyrants are supporting make America
great
again is that is that what he's saying
is that what he's
saying oh wait a second wait a second I
think um I think we got an updated image
speaking of AI H we got oh my God he is
Don Jr is testifying in court and open
court and boy is it a wild ride there in
New York look at that white powdered
everywhere and he's got five fingers so
this has got to be Don Jr right is this
real or is this
AI is it real
or is
it I know that stick is getting annoying
but is it real or is it AI I don't know
that looks like a hell of a lot of
cocaine this could be
real some people are saying nope too
young no beard I mean he's got a shadow
maybe he just shaved a little bit you
know what I
mean but he's got he's got five fingers
on each hand and it's a lot of cocaine
and I'm not sure why this guy this guy
in the background is on has a microphone
here that's kind of weird isn't it so
there's the five-fingered one oh no
that's the wrong direction Donald Trump
has the right amount of fingers on that
one and here's the one here's the the
fine fingered
one um I don't know but let's go back to
the video because I think the video I
want to I want you to listen to this
video one more time I had to laugh when
I heard this listen listen real close
what he says again this is your chance
to take a stand against tyrants that
support the one and only movement that
can save our country and make America
great again the tyrants that support the
movement
now this is real I mean I I want it not
I want it to be real but I want it to be
fake too right there's so much
complexity here when we're talking about
this clip where he's basically admitting
by objection and if aian lip that MAA is
a bunch of tyrants right I mean listen
do it again this is your chance to take
a stand against tyrants that support the
one and only movement that can save our
country and make America great
again okay so make America great again
is supported by
tyrants you know what's crazy about this
being real and my my friend Jeremy
London uh pointed this this out uh on on
Twitter uh you let me let me get to let
me get that up Jeremy London says that
he says he literally said not to follow
the manga movement but yeah keep
knocking Biden's mental decline right I
mean this is weird stuff now the thing
about it is is that Jeremy Jeremy London
is an actor he's a director like he's a
producer he knows how like I don't know
moving pictures
work like literally when you record
something you can edit it and if you
[__] it up the first time you can just
like re-shoot it like literally when
Trump's standing in front of the camera
and he's you know puking up his garbage
his fascist trash out of his mouth if he
says something wrong they can catch it
because they can replay it pretty quick
and then he can go stand there again and
say it the right
way so is it the intention of the Trump
of trump and his social media team to
put this clip out
where he's saying this this is your
chance to take a stand against tyrants
that support the one and only movement
that can save our country and make
America great again this is your so
there you have it this is your one
chance
to view the tyrants because he's the
Tyrant here good chance to take a stand
against tyrants that support the one and
only movement can save our country yeah
you you are right we are we are going to
take the chance to stand against these
tyrants that are trying to have a
movement that is pretending to save the
country and what they mean is the white
Christian nationalist of this country
wow that's crazy stuff and again is it
real or is it hi now the best part is is
that um the actual video here is put out
by the Biden Harris headquarters on
Twitter um and here's here's what they
say the Biden haris this account is
[__] banging by the way I don't know
if you like this is dark Brandon through
and through if you're wanting dark
Brandon tweets this is where to go to
get it like this is direct from the
Biden campaign it says Trump on the 2024
election this is your chance to stand
against tyrants that support the Maga
movement oh [__] that's
hilarious oh my God that's great
how did how did Trump not catch this
really how did they not catch this
that's what I want to know it can't be
that hard to catch this stuff right well
it might be because they are buffoons
and they continue to be buffoons and
they continue to goof themselves here's
Newsmax talking about Joe Biden passing
out candy on Halloween this is a real
clip too this is
real there he is being himself uh great
stuff there and uh Dr Jill Biden she for
Halloween she was a doctor and for
Halloween Joe Biden was President of the
United States okay so obviously the
comedy is [__] he's trying to make jokes
right oh there's Joe Biden being himself
yeah he was being himself he was handing
out kid candy to kids on Halloween you
weird
[__] like how don't you know
this stuff that the president of United
States no matter who it is hands out
candy to kids on Halloween it's like a
thing it's like
American culture you know Halloween's
part of our culture and Society here I
mean [__] it's designed to sell all
kinds of retail items it's the whole
point of it right it's retail money
money money money money money I mean
that's just well come on don't give me
any [__] that's what H Halloween has
been commercialized same way
Thanksgiving and New Year's and
Christmas has been commercialized in
this country and people like this love
that [__] but he's trying to make a joke
about Dr Joe Biden if you didn't catch
it this [__] bonee head's like she
tried to pretend to be a
doctor oh good one you [__] bonehead
but listen to where it where it slides
into they can't go [__] 10 minutes
without idolizing Hitler on on Newsmax
listen to this [__] uh Dr Jill actually
was dressed up like a cat like she's a
17-year-old high school girl or
something and she said they put the
makeup like the cat mouth Hunter a lot
of people thought it looked like a
Hitler
mustache this is what they're saying
looks like a Hitler
mustache now yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm pretty
good at goofing right and I could goof
on Dr Joe
Biden about this face paint I mean I
could it is possible I could go on and
on and on probably for 30 minutes but I
I mean you know it's Halloween so what
am I going to do it's Halloween she was
dressed up as a cat she's got cat ears
on so she put the face paint on right
like any person who's dressed up as a
cat would for crying out [__] loud
but give me a break this is the [__]
this is a Hitler
mustache this is a Hitler mustache this
is what no this is not even close to a
Hitler face like me looking at this and
goofing there's no way I would say I
mean Hitler didn't have the mustache on
his
nose the [__] are they talking about
about they're obsessed with Hitler you
notice that they're [__] obsessed
with it like honestly I wish we could
stop talking about
Hitler gez the only reason why we got to
talk about it is because they idolize a
[__] so much they're posting his
quotes on on on [__] with
casserole's
newsletters this moms for
tyranny right you know this group
the [__] mini man
Taliban moms for tyranny who want to do
away with public education so that our
country is [__] dumber than dog [__]
so that they think that this is a Hitler
mustache Jesus Christ are you kidding
me I wish Ronda santis would denounce
the Nazis that support him in Florida
that's what I wish that way we wouldn't
have to talk about [__] Nazis and
Hitler I wish Republicans would stop
backing Neo-Nazi policies like these
bathroom bills and anti-d drag bills
these [__] bigoted sons of [__]
then we wouldn't have to [__] talk
about this
[__] but they're completely [__]
obsessed you got you got half the
[__] Republicans funded including our
Supreme Court Justices funded by Haron
Hitler a Texas billionaire who has a
signed copy of mine cof and he's showing
it off and then on news maxter talking
about how this people are saying that
this looks like a Hitler mustache
what no people are not saying people are
saying you sound like you're [__]
dumb when you think that this looks like
a Hitler mustache but okay continue it
gets worse I know you don't think it's G
to get but oh it gets way worse they go
and just let me play it kids I think the
the kids probably weren't from the
neighborhood if I would be working in
the communications team I would have
just said close press we're gonna send
out a photo and call it a day he looks
ridiculous he looks creepy he looks like
a hot mess and I don't want my children
near him what are you talking about he
was passing out candy to children who
were standing in line to get
candy what the [__] [__] are they
talking about again I like goofing on
Trump but I think one of the dumbest
ways to goof on him is when he's passing
out hand candy for Halloween there's so
many better opportunities to goof on
these [__] dumb bastards there's so
many better ways to goof on them than
than him passing out candy this is dumb
I showed you the video yesterday where
the RNC research posted the video of him
passing out candy and he dropped a box
of candy and he he picked it up off the
ground oh dare he what the [__] are you
talking about this is weird stuff that
these people are diving into but listen
where it goes they're not only obsessed
with Hitler listen to what else they're
[__] obsessed with listen to this I
think he was sniffing the kids I thought
he gave them the little cheek kiss um
which something that some people do with
babies and you know we're making fun of
him for coughing in his hand I I don't
and then passing the candy to the kids
grabbing the
candy time let Biden out in public you
know there's going to be some good
content he's going to be creepy with
kids he's going to be awkward he's going
to be coughing he's going to be
stumbling and fumbling over his words
maybe tripping on stairs all I know is
I'm going to the schaps house for
Halloween you guys out good candy bars
so whoa whoa the schlap house wait a
second oh that's right folks that's Matt
schlap there on the end I don't know if
oh let me Point him out uh right there
this is Matt
schlap the closeted gay who has been
accused of molesting [__] on
their campaign grabbing them in the
crotch that's right they're making these
jokes sitting here about Biden how about
how [__] creepy he is and this son of
a [__] on the end is a [__] sexual
predator that's right and they're all
yucking it up Biden's a creep because
he's handing out candy to kids on
Halloween all the while the [__] the
the dick groper over here is yucking it
up too and they're all going to go to
the slap's house and get grabbed by Matt
schap I guess I guess that's what they
think Halloween's
about get the [__] out of here with this
[__] crazy
[__] are you are you [__]
me this can't be real right this has
gotta be AI it's got to be AI with match
slap sitting here as these people are
yucking it up about someone being a
sexual predator when they got a [__]
sexual predator sitting at the goddamn
table with them are you [__] kidding
me and then the one [__] says that
they're gonna they're all gonna go to
the slaps house where I guess you get
that I mean that's normal stuff where
you get sexually molested on Halloween
I'm sure if the schlap sounds get the
[__] out of here this is the [__] that
these people are listening
to and you're wondering why why your
farm fresh fash Facebook Uncle Fred is
delusional [__] delusional and oh by
the way speaking of your your farm fresh
fash Facebook Uncle Fred it appears that
we're not g to have the government open
by
Thanksgiving I know I know I'm laughing
at it it's not really a laughable matter
but you know what it just shows how
inept they
are it just shows how inept are I mean
here they are on Newsmax could report on
decent [__] [__] and here I am having
to goof on
them and show you this [__] that they're
watching this sludge that they're
pumping into these [__] people's puny
little manga brains where they ain't got
enough [__] brain cells to rub
together and that's why they're [__]
out [__]
turds Jesus
Christ I mean at least Newsmax could
have some goddamn integrity
since they got the word news in their
name they're clearly not [__] news
clearly but they got the [__] name or
the word in their name they could at
least
try to get some news out that yeah the
government's going to shut down not only
that it doesn't look like the
Republicans are going to pass funding
for Israel or Ukraine for that
matter not not going to do it doesn't
look like it to me I mean some people
people are still staying optimistic
around Washington some commentators are
optimistic in Mike Johnson's ability
what
ability what a speak speaking of weirdos
and Matt schlap and people doing weird
things with
Children what about questioning why Mike
Johnson at the age of 25 as a single
man adopted a 14-year-old boy how about
that how about that you [__] weirdos
at Newsmax why you're sitting around the
table with a sexual predator casting
your projections onto Joe
Biden Jesus [__] Christ it never it's
just astounding to me and again this is
why I I almost doubt that this is even
real because this can't be real right
this can't
be but it is it is
real literally they biggest [__]
knock on Joe Biden now now I want to
tell you a little bit about this
week there's been a lot of stuff going
on this week but there is a there was a
huge Victory this week for the American
workers when Chevrolet finally announced
a ta a tentative agreement with the UAW
and I know that that feels like well
that ain't that big a [__] it ain't
that's a big [__] deal that's a
really big [__]
deal that's a huge win in the Biden
column folks for what can be used in the
narrative for the American working class
next year in the general election it's a
big [__] win and this CVS Walgreens
[__] if this gets worked out with a
strike the same thing because I almost
bet I almost bet that this President of
the United States who is the most pro-
American middle class president that I
have ever
seen probably since
FDR that this this pro-american middle
class working middle class president
will stay with those CVS and those and
those Walgreen workers and anyone else
who decides to strike to get their
[__] fair share of the GDP and the
profits that these companies use their
labor
for he's goingon to stand with those
American workers and that's a huge win
in the column this week and you know
what's crazy is these [__]
can't even find a way to goof that think
about that for a second think about it
for a second they're sitting around a
table with a [__] accused sexual
predator sitting at the
end who is apparently a closeted gay man
who grabs dudes by the dick in a car and
sexually molest them okay that's what
he's [__] accused of don't come at me
that's what he's accused of they're
sitting around the table talking about
how Joe Biden's a sexual predator when
what they should be doing if they were a
good opposition if they were a good
opposition what they would be doing is
they would be trying to find a way to
spend a narrative that it's bad that the
unions are winning these fights which
that's the
point they can't find a way to spin a
narrative where it is good for the
American working class to not win these
labor Wars against these corporations
they can't do it they can't do it they
understand they understand that the
American people no matter who you are
whether you're for Biden or for Trump
whether you're for unions or against
unions it doesn't [__] matter when it
comes down to it when the question is
should workers get paid a decent [__]
wage especially when the corporation
they work for has mountains of
profit should they earn a decent [__]
wage they absolutely should earn a
decent [__] wage
and my guess is my guess is is that no
matter your ideology no matter where you
stand on a political Spectrum you will
agree with that statement that the
American working class deserves a decent
[__] wage and they deserve their fair
share of the profits of those
corporations that they work for and
that's why Newsmax is projecting as the
sexual molester sits at the end of the
table molesting
pumpkins oh wait I have a I have an
image of Matt SL schlap
here looks like he's trying to get his
hands on that
pumpkin weird stuff weird stuff in
American politics look at
that oh rat you're something else
everybody think than the lab Rand you
rat bastard you rat bastard you really
are something you know
that good oh this guy this [__] guy
we're talking about match schlap
molesting it's Halloween the day after
Halloween and he produces this image how
does that make you feel about yourself
rant a he's excited he's excited about
it well thank you R thanks for the
images today we'll keep going maybe
we'll find some more all right let's
keep going
um I don't know actually you know what
let's finish it up let's see if let's
see if match laap says anything here at
the end I don't think he does but let's
see if he responds in any way to her
inviting herself to the molestation
party I mean the Halloween party with
kids he's gonna be awkward he's gonna be
coughing he's gonna be stumbling and
fumbling over his words maybe tripping
on stairs all I know is I'm going to the
schaps house for Halloween because you
guys out good candy bars so you know
forget the White
House oh they're gonna have good wine
did you hear that that's he said at the
end listen listen to MHL if you hear him
you can hear him talk listen you guys
good candy bars so you know forget the
White House and we'll have good wine I
get you nice and drunk before I grab
you well you get you get you nice and
wasted give you that good
candy that good candy and that good wine
all right before you get a good grabing
Jesus Christ are you [__] kidding
me how in the hell don't they see this
stuff
right I mean you know the mustache thing
the the Hitler mustache thing that was
some heavy [__] lifting wasn't it
that was some heavy [__] lifting but
then sitting around the table projecting
their [__] weird
Obsession about molesting people
projecting it on someone
else
while while having a an accused sexual
predator who molested men on the
campaign
Trail and that that that's what we're
going to
do all right all right I do have an
image here um this yesterday this just
came in from Arkansas you know that
there's a big huge Scandal speaking of
[__] in the Republican party and
people who support Trump uh this was
Sarah hunab Sanders she apparently had
uh she apparently went to mat slap's
house uh is it real or is it a die I
don't know maybe it's
photoshopped I really like that image
yesterday that image made me
happy on Halloween so all right let's
get let's get [__] serious here as if
we can get serious here is um here's the
I showed you I tell I told you I was
gonna play the clip of Josh Holly
getting absolutely torched by my orcus
and here it is now in the leadup to this
what had happened was is that Josh Holly
had showed an image that a DHS employee
wrongfully should have not have put that
message on their Instagram I mean it's
their free speech they can post [__] on
Instagram as they want but when you are
part of the DHS here in America and
you're you're an employee of our great
bureaucratic institution like the
homeland security it's probably not a
good idea to be posting pramas
propaganda on your Instagram page page
just saying probably not a good idea and
that that employee did um but Josh Holly
kind of stepped in here and here is that
my orc's response to Josh Hy just
absolutely watting him up and dunking
him in the [__] trash watch frankly
Mr secretary I think that your
performance is Despicable and I think
the fact that you are not willing to
provide answers to this committee is
absolutely
atrocious he's
outraged he's he's just
outraged he's outraged he must not get
invited to the slap molestation
Halloween party at Josh Holly he really
wanted to go and stand next to to Matt
schlap drink the special wine and eat
the good
candy talking about closeted all right
but let's watch my orchid's response as
he [__] again totally puts dunks him
in the [__] trash here Mr chairman
may I yeah oh damn like if you'd like to
have a a minute to respond you I would
I'm not sure I'll limit it to 60 seconds
number one uh what I found despicable is
the
implication uh that uh this language
tremendously OD um uh actually it could
be
emblematic of the sentiments of the
260,000 men and women of the Department
of Homeland Security number one number
two uh Senator Holly takes a
adversarial approach to me in this
question and perhaps he doesn't know my
own background
uhoh does not know that I am the child
of a holocaust Survivor oops perhaps he
does not know that my mother lost almost
all her
family at the hands of the Nazis and so
I find his adversarial tone to be
entirely
misplaced I find to be disrespectful of
me and my Heritage and I do not expect
an apology but I did want to say what I
just articulated thank you Mr chairman
can can I just respond since he has
referenced me personally Senator H we
need to move on
Senator no no [__] no you can't I'm not
gonna let you em actually the chairman
should have let Holly embarrass himself
because look at this look right here
Holly knew he [__] up look at this
look at this he's sitting there thinking
oh [__] I had no idea I had no idea that
this guy's mother was a holocaust
Survivor and her entire family was
cooked in an oven and and murdered and
executed by the Nazis that I shall want
to stoke in this country that I love to
stoke the Nazis in this country like the
Nazis down on the bridge in Florida the
Nazis in Ohio protesting drag queens I
want those Nazis in this country to do
what the Nazis did in Germany I had no
idea that's right Josh H's a [__]
Nazi he's a Christof fascist he's a
white Christian
Nationalist and he deserved this [__]
ass spanking that my my orcus gave to
him that little [__] [__] this
little [__] [__] here Josh Holly that
piece of trash how how [__] how
[__] dare he call in the Secretary of
DHS and act like a post on one of the
DHS employees on their private account
not only represents the entirety of the
DHS but the Biden
Administration and to not give him
proper proper way to respond in that and
not give him the proper respect not only
that to [__] cash dispersements on my
orcus not even
knowing of my orc's family [__]
history and why it is so important to my
orcus of why that [__] post would be
offensive you piece of [__] trash
Josh Holly and I am so glad that my
orcus punched back at him and did this
to him and embarrassed him in front of
the world the problem is in in in our
state now that we're in in this country
so many things are more important than
what just happened here but this to
people the people things are so more
important but this exchange here is so
[__] important I wanna I want you to
watch it again Mr secretary I think that
your performance is Despicable and I
think the fact that you are not willing
to provide answers to this committee is
absolutely atrocious I I wonder if this
is how Josh holley's wife talks to him
you know what I mean Josh you just I I
know you like to watch that kind of porn
but that kind of porn just isn't
Christian okay that kind of porn it
doesn't make you a man
it doesn't make you a man and it's
atrocious that you watch that kind of
porn you know what I'm talking about you
know what I'm talking about she's
[__] yeah someone Robbie says
pretentious little [__] yeah he is he's
a pretentious little [__] and so is his
wife have you seen interviews with him
and his wife talking those pretentious
[__] white Christian
nationalist goddamn Christof fascist
[__] want to tell us want to
tell us how we're going to live our
lives when this son of a [__] doesn't
even live in Missouri he represents
Missouri doesn't even [__] live
there he does even live in our [__]
State and he wants to tell us how to
[__] live this closeted [__] piece
of [__] I don't care if you're gay Josh
I don't give a [__] I don't care if you
and Tom Cotton run around you know
holding hands and going and having you
know cocaine sex ories with Lindsey
Graham and Matt schlap I don't give a
[__] whatever you want to do man you do
you you just stay the [__] out of
everyone else's [__] life
and the other thing you probably should
do or you should at least think about
doing is at least [__] looking up who
the [__] your test or who you're
questioning during testimony and cashing
casting Aparments on them you [__]
piece of trash again like Robbie said
he's such a pretentious little [__] all
right let's watch the dunking in the
trash again I think it's worth
it Mr chairman may I like if you'd like
to have a a minute to respond you were I
would and I'm not sure I'll limit it to
60 seconds that's fine number one uh
what I found despicable is the
implication uh that uh this language
tremendously odious um uh actually could
be
emblematic of the sentiments of the
260,000 men and women of the Department
of Homeland Security number one number
two uh Senator Holly takes a adversarial
approach approach to me in this question
and perhaps he doesn't know my own
background perhaps he does not know that
I am the child of a holocaust
Survivor perhaps he does not know that
my mother lost almost all her
family at the hands of the Nazis and so
I find his adversarial tone to be
entirely
misplaced I find it to be disrespectful
of me and my look at that chicken [__]
[__] look at him look at that
chicken [__] piece of [__] look at him
he's going oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] oh
[__] I want to apologize to him now I
have to apologize this is gonna be bad
look at
that little [__] placed I find it to be
disrespectful of me and my
Heritage and I do not expect an apology
but I did want to say what I just
articulated thank you Mr chairman can
can I just respond since he has
referenced me personally Senator PA we
need to move on Senator I I want to show
you another face in this that I see
watch watch uh Mitt Romney right
here watch watch Mitt Romney's face this
is hilarious you guys know Mitt Romney
isn't seeking reelection he got he ain't
got a [__] to give watch Mitt Romney is
so happy he's smiling there smiling that
my arc is just [__] dun T in the
chash and he thinks it's funny that
Holly thinks he's gonna
respond because you know what Mitt
Romney's thinking oh God I hope they let
him stick his foot in his [__] mouth
just do it just let Holly [__] just
eat the rake throw that rake out there
and jump on it Holly that's what Mitt
Romney's thinking here look at him he's
smiling he's like you stupid
bastard oh my
God dumb son of [__] godd damn you
can't get any dumber than that you know
what Robbie's right maybe we should make
some merch you know we got the uh the
merch
here even my dog hates Ted Curry
which I guess Josh Holly is the next up
to bat here even my dog hates hates
hates Josh Holly but maybe may
maybe maybe Robbie's right you just go
to the Tony michaels.com to grab this
you just pan on down to the even my dog
hates dead merch but maybe it should be
my dog wouldn't piss on Josh
Holly even my dog wouldn't piss on Josh
hly thank you Robbie for your comments
here today in the U in the chat all
right uh we've got some news coming
across the uh the wires here it is about
Republicans two House GOP members uh
Olivia beavers has it here two House GOP
retirement announcements today in
addition to Granger uh here it
is Buck told me last August told me in
August excuse me in August that he did
plan to run for re-election despite many
in his district wondering if he would
are you running for re-election yes how
long do you think you'll stay in the
house hope hope another 16 months uh
GOP Colorado representative Ken Buck
tells Mitchell reports he will not seek
re-election to
Congress so it looks like another one
bites the dust now as you know kin Buck
has recently been in the news because
Ken Buck was the one who was supposed to
be asking Jim Jordan do you believe that
the 2020 election was still stolen and
Jim Jordan wouldn't respond to him and
that's one reason why it took Jim Jordan
three times three strikes you're out
right Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan and we got an image here
apparently of Josh Hy let's see if we
can go back oh my God look at this oh
man they're arguing over his porn look
here here's a here's a glimpse right
inside the Holly house oh my God caught
him looking at that suspicious porn that
she thinks is unchristian and
ungodly and stuff does not make you a
man does not make you a
man this is this real or is it AI I
don't know I think it I think it looks
pretty real folks the one thing you
shouldn't do is spread this around the
internet like it's real but yeah maybe
they'll ask the question is it real or
is it is
[Music]
so uh you know what you don't want to do
is spread this image around the internet
maybe we'll tweet this out or put it in
Discord that way you can find
it [__] them [__] them what are they
gonna do or sue me go ahead Josh hly sue
me do it send me a cease and assist
thank you send me a cease and assist
limiting my speech sh do it I dare you
let me show it to you one more time why
not there's Josh Holly it looks real
this looks [__] real and his wife
catching him looking at a certain kind
of porn I mean you're going to have to
decide what kind of porn he's got on his
computer there I mean it's really going
to be up to you to decide I mean we
can't see it we can't confirm it you
know what I
mean
but here you
go oh boy oh boy you know I just got the
link from Gabe Sanchez and uh Gabe
Sanchez is going to be live right after
this show that's right right after this
show on YouTube and twitch Gabe Sanchez
with what was that live right after the
show I'm not sure if he's gonna join us
here but he might he may oh let's see
what else other news did I have to that
I wanted to go over I had a few more
clips that I wanted to show you I
promise here uh oh this little clip our
lead story our lead story booger sugar
Jr so let's do this let's take a quick
break when we come back I'm gonna show
you the clip of booger sugar Jr
testifying to the AG and this was back
in July of 2022 when he was talking
about the Gap that's right Don Jr was
talking about not the Gap in his nose
where the blow goes in he was talking
about accounting practices and how he
knows not [__] about them so don't go
anywhere we'll talk about that right
after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tammy by the time we reach d
see weight was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin bro in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show booger sugar Jr
ttif find an open court today's November
1st tomorrow is heric
Trump Wednesday November 3rd is
ianka Kushner now Formerly Known As
Trump she changed her name because I
don't know got kind of shitty to have
that last name didn't it the brand
wasn't there
anymore oh [__]
ianka is not on this um this lawsuit her
name isn't Eric and Don Jr's is ianas
was left off after some some appeals um
so ianka is really not at risk here
other than you know what she may or may
not lie to an open
court but I mean I guess I guess my
question is and by the way I want to
also tell you this that November 6th is
bound to be a great day too November 6th
is the day that Donald Trump testifies
in open court I don't know how many
fists he'll be taking but you know yes
Captain turps says the statue of
limitations it was the statue of
limitations that prevented ianka moved
on and was was trying to get uh her own
Chinese trademarks when he was the
president and also he was trying trying
to get that two two billion Saudi money
you know what I'm talking about that
that great Saudi money so the statue of
limitations ran out on her and they won
that but you know I mean she could turn
on turn on no lap daddy you know I'm
talking about she used to sit on his lap
a lot um and there's this there's a um
there's a clip that on Howard Stern Show
oh my God there's a clip on Howard Stern
Show of of aanka and Donald Trump
basically admitting that he's a sexual
predator like it exists it's a thing uh
maybe I'll show that to you but you know
what I want to show show you a clip of
Don Jr but wait wait a second wait wait
wait wait we got do we have some music
playing
here
[Music]
laste this is with the
last I think he's
here live and in
color gab Sanchez Che chop Cheeto chop
Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
Cheeto chop all right all right
[Music]
how you
doing what's going on good morning we're
getting we're finally getting down to
some of the clips of the lead story
where Don Jr is booger sugar Jor
testifying an open cor let me show you
some of the images that we have um from
the courtroom I think I think you'll
like this one best uh here this is an
image that we have from the courtroom
here of Don Jr apparently about to
testify he brought in the goodies w wow
well you know you never know how long
you're going to have to testify so you
might need some you know Go Go Juice you
know what I mean I mean it is it is hold
on I just want to put this out there it
is November 1st which technically means
that you could start playing a certain
song by Mariah carry and that might
indicate that there's I don't know the
holidays and that there might be snow
coming so this honestly makes sense some
fresh powder you know the holiday season
upcoming so you're saying you're saying
like white Christmas
I'm Dreaming oh well of course it's
always a white Christmas for white
Christmas you know that sort of thing is
that yeah yeah yeah let's see if you can
sing yeah yeah yeah let's see exactly
that's I mean that's all I got that's
that's that's all I gu just in the
background here just to just like you
know just add a little I'm just here to
harmonize you know I'm not here to sing
the lyrics I'm just here to harmonize
I'm just the background dancer of this
song but what I will say is yes it does
make sense to me um if I were Don Jr and
I'm not but sometimes I play Don Jr
entering the mind of what is going on
with him and I can totally understand
that you know the guy's got social
anxiety he has a coping mechanism he has
become dependent and leans on it heavily
in many ways that his father has leaned
on you're talking about cocaine I think
you're talking about cocaine is that
what you're talking about look I don't
know if it's cocaine or cocen or
whatever you want to call it man but
what it is it's Don Jr going to
inevitably throw this whole it's he's
gonna look Don Jr is going to try to
appease his father and he's gonna try to
make his
dad proud and as a result he's going to
throw this case to the
prosecution like there's no other way to
look at he's going to do what he does I
don't know Joe Biden okay Joe but you
know and then Don jun's gonna come and
he's like Daddy I'm here you know deep
State deep State well here's here is
here's a little glimpse into this is the
best look at how is that is that is that
powder or is that just old age I have no
idea I don't know I don't know if he
buried his his face in the pile of
cocaine that we just saw before this
then this was July 28
2022 um this is a a deposition that he
gave that he was forced to give I don't
know if you remember that they really
tried hard not to and Eric Trump like
went he he he played the F like 500
times or something over 500 times now I
very excited for him to show up tomorrow
because I can only imagine that he's
going to do the same thing he did and
who knows I mean but probably assume
that he's going to plead the fifth wa
wait wait we have some I got an image
here of of Don Jr booger sugar Jr
apparently uh oh this is a different
kind of fifth I'm sorry oh that's him
that's him taking the fifth that's him
that's him taking a drink of the fifth
not taking the little different okay
well I saw I saw I saw a similar image
of from from Paul EES oh okay yeah yeah
yeah and he was it was holding a bottle
of Jack Daniels Jack Daniels okay well
why I I thought he would if we would get
him to take the fifth not drink the
fifth but the well you know I'm just
saying it's drink the fifth take the
fifth you know it's all kind of the same
thing I guess I mean who knows you know
what's funny about manga yeah you know
what's funny about manga is they they
they they think they know the First
Amendment which I talked about in
beginning year they have no clue what
the first amendment is and then they the
only one they really know and they get
they get [__] boners is the second
one because they're like guns yeah right
now they know about the fifth one
because their their political party has
to continually take the fifth like all
the time like it's a continuous thing
Time After Time After Time rather than
drinking it or they're taking the fifth
you know yeah I mean it's
uh for people Republicans especially
they love to say I'm a constitutionalist
I know the bill of Rise I'm a man the
Declaration of
Independence Nick Cage okay so Nick Cage
is that yeah you mean like National
Treasure type [__] do they think that's
you think those are they think those are
documentaries is what you're saying I
think I think they think that it was a
real thing that happened and they're
like oh this is clearly Nick Cage doing
a dramatization
of something has happened but when I
look at rep we got wait we got we got a
we got a mad R Mad Lab Rat back there
and I almost bet he could get us a good
image of Nick Cage doing something wild
and crazy um I don't know maybe as a
manga supporter or something like that
I'm sure he could he could get something
going so I'm just saying ni that's a big
name that's a big face I don't but I
don't want to tarnish I don't want to
tarnish the name of Nick Cage and put
him on Maga well I mean can tarnish Nick
Cage morning dis well you know what
let's play this clip because I bet well
if we see if we can come up with
something um well not this clip this
clip here remember you can switch
between there we go yeah see I got it no
I got it I can't believe you I can't
believe you taught me something that's
amazing well you know what I do truly is
amazing what I do you taught me
something that's amazing so here here
old dogs can new Lear
guess learn new tricks they can they can
they can they can they can teach them
them them learn the dogs than them news
tricks and stuff well you know what I I
think that Don Jr wishes about this clip
that he could go back and take the fifth
on this clip because this clip makes him
look dumb as [__] but let's let's listen
to this have any familiarity with an
acronym Gap Gap p generally accepted
accounting principles yes okay how did
you become familiar with that acronym
probably an Accounting 101 at Wharton Ed
Wharton Ed Wharton I went to the best
business school ever in the history of
ever it's Wharton no one knows but I a
great business person and my son Don Jr
he also went there which proves that
Warton is full of [__] when it claims
it's one of the best business schools
ever East Coast he's go IV League
elitist that's what we are oh yeah
Pennsylvania University of Pennsylvania
business school Wharton oh God Hand me
another one hand me another
adall oh yeah that's good you know I
love I love when they step in this stuff
when they're like oh Democrats are all
elitist and they're going to the Wharton
School of Business Ed
[Laughter]
snorton
all right Ed snorton uh you know you're
just going to give a labat all kinds of
crazy ideas I know I I saw it and I was
like I gotta bring this up Ed snorton
that's great red rocket red rocket on
YouTube gave us that okay so he's
talking about you know here he's trying
to show his Elite status right that I
hey look I know what Gap is okay I went
to the business school of Wharton and
then and then she's like oh really okay
well tell us about that okay um what do
they teach you
about accepted accounting principles in
won did you look at the look on his face
he's like oh [__] well that I don't oh
damn wait hold on wait who nobody said
this deposition was gonna be a pop
quiz he he immediately knows that oh I
just [__] myself right like he's like
that [__] but also it was a I mean it's
a catch 22 because what happens is they
say oh do you know what Gap is and he
goes no I don't and then she would say
well didn't you go to the Wharton School
of Business at the University of
Pennsylvania and he goes oh yes I did
and then she would say well isn't
Accounting 101 like isn't Gap covered in
Accounting 101 which is a required core
senator in order to get your business
degree and he go well yeah and then she
goes okay so you don't know anything
about that and he goes well no makes him
look like an idiot then the other side
is this is like when you ask there was
an interview with Donald Trump um
and I forget the author but they were
asking Donald Trump if he reads any
books and Donald Trump this is years ago
Donald Trump was like oh I I read um I
think it last name wolf I'm blanking on
the first name but he was like oh I read
the Thomas wolf wolf Thomas wolf yeah
yeah and they were like oh did you read
the latest book and he goes oh no I
haven't read it and they're like oh
what's the most recent book you read he
goes oh well I love Thomas wolf and
they're like oh and they go around
asking the question of like was it the
most recent one he goes oh yeah yeah and
they're like oh can you tell us more
about it he goes oh well you know he's
doing wonderful things Thomas wolf
really knows how to put pen to paper and
caught him in a lie and so in this
situation with Don Jor is the same thing
either he says he doesn't know what it
is or he says he knows what it is and he
gets [__] either way well let's see
what his response is because it's even
worse than you're describing well I'm
not an accountant but that they are
generally
accepted what the [__] so so basically
he knows he knows that Gap stands for
the thing that it stands for that's all
he knows he doesn't know anything beyond
that that's it that's all he knows
that's all he knows well may maybe I'm
maybe I'm off my rocker here let let's
see I'll let him finish let's see if he
knows anything let's see if she has any
follow-up questions anything else that's
that's pretty much what I remember from
Accounting
101 not only what he remembers from Gap
but what he remembers from all of
Accounting 101 this is what this guy
remembers now he's the executive VI is a
Executive Vice President of the Trump
organization and the [__] he's
testifying today is [__] he signed
signed off on the financials and this
guy is telling you out loud that he's no
accountant and the only thing that he
remembers from Accounting 101 is what
the acronym Gap stands for I and I have
you told me everything no go ahead go
ahead no I'm gonna I'm going to uh
safely assume here that if look I went
to Business School and I I I almost
became an accountant up until my junior
year and then I was like what the [__]
am I doing I hate myself I was in
Advanced Tax and I and I stood up you
did you did
what what you you you were gonna be an
accountant I was I was on the track to
becoming an accountant before I my
junior year I stood up in class not
knowing what was happening we were going
it was like few days into Advan tax and
what happened was I stood up and I was
like God what am I doing
here no you stood up and said that out
loud well no sorry I I said it out loud
and then what happened was everyone
looked at me and I didn't realize that I
said it loud and the professor turned
around and said excuse me and then at
that point I stood up and was like uh
and I left went to my Dean and I was
like look I need to change my major and
then ended up just was able to swap it
out because I was taking other business
courses and did not change the track
that I was on but it came to junior year
and I was like I don't actually enjoy
anything I'm doing and I have friends
who are CPAs now and they enjoy
themselves that's great but I got are
you sure are you sure they just fake it
because I mean it seems like a they
could be but I do know some I mean like
I there was one girl I went to school
with her mother was a professor and they
loved [__] accounting like that they
they got off on accounting oh my god
well this guy doesn't like accounting
watch her followup here it's
hilarious have you told me everything
you know about C my
basically you know I'm sure I could come
up with some creative uh stuff to kill
time but I'd be doing neither of us a
favor in terms of educating
ourselves I can make a bunch of Lies up
like I always do but that wouldn't do
any good because then you'd probably
catch me I mean it's crazy but also not
surprising that someone who was in
charge of I think he was at least in
charge of two different large assets on
the books the two buildings that they're
talking about and the the fact that he
wasn't able to I mean like his Gap goes
through like cost and you know fair
market value and also what you're
assessing to make sure you're you know
disclosing and matching and all your
Revenue things like that and so the fact
that this guy is signing off on
something probably didn't even remember
what Gap stood for before he walked into
the step position they probably were
like look we got a list the questions
he's going to ask about financial stuff
you might want to have at least the
acronyms down and he's like all right
cool cool cool cool that's all all
they'll ask and they're like who knows
but you could at least start there and
that's all he that's quick skim quick
skim before this deposition well they
knew they were gonna ask him about the
they knew they were gonna ask him about
financials but you know who am I to say
I mean these people believe that the
Nick Cage movie where he's stealing the
the Declaration of Independence is real
but we actually have a picture a real
picture of Nick Cage stealing Don Jr's
Jacko Lantern here yesterday on
Halloween so this is ni cage stealing
the Jack of' Lantern so we didn't
disparage him too much there's Nick Cage
no wait wait wait I got more I've got
more we've got uh your Ed snorton here
Ed snort God joining Donald Donald Trump
Jr before the deposition Edward Norton
is gonna come after us and say you know
what Ed snorton Ed snort there might be
a project there head snorton uh here uh
you know you know this is our Free
Speech what is he going to do send me a
cease and assist go ahead Ed snorton
send me a Sease anded assist that would
be Fant sneeze a sneeze and I don't know
I think I think I would get you know
with the pumpkin and the and the
snorting I think I would get probably a
cease and assist from match laap before
that here's one we had of him earlier
match slap likes to molest pumpkins here
he was yesterday on Halloween wowow
molesting a pumpkin we were talking
about him earlier here's another image
that I think you'll love um this is this
is Josh holl wife catching him watching
a certain type of non- manly porn here
um so there's this um and I've got I've
got one that the audience hasn't seen
yet so I wanna I want to show you this
is another image of your farm fresh fash
Facebook Uncle Fred and he's really
excited about the government shutdown uh
at Thanksgiving yay government shutdown
shut garbage shut
down this going to be great we're going
to blame this on bad okay good luck
Uncle friend what are you g to talk
about today on what was that live well
I'm gonna talk about Don Jr yeah um and
I'm gonna talk about Alina habba and I'm
going to talk about what else is going
on man it's like it's what what the [__]
is else you know again this is stuff I
just [__] winging you know this guy
come in with an idea and then we just
see where it goes yesterday we literally
for the whole hour we broke down and and
I know exactly and I don't want to
reveal it too much here because I talked
on the show yesterday and I'm going to
do what was that on it but okay uh I
know the source the
origin of
where uh where Ronda sanz's
phobia or insecurity around boots and
shoes came from he was 18 that's all
I'll say but I have I have it down to a
science I know exactly what happened I
know what he felt about it and also
leads into his anti-government
regulation type of [__] but we
covered that yesterday which I thought
was pretty funny everyone was having a
good time we were talking about boots
boot gate just new boot new boot goofing
more more people are are goofing on
Ronda sanz's boots than than Mike
Johnson's 14-year-old son that he
adopted when he was a 25-year old single
man it's that's also another that's
another story that I'm going to jump on
uh as I've been easy on the easy okay
that's another story that I'm going to
approach right okay great that's that's
much approach with
consent um you know here's here here
here's here's a great here's a great
transition here for you to go to what
was that live on the story of of Ronda
santis and
um and Don Jr here's a clip of Don Jr I
think oh yeah yeah explaining let's
let's listen to this how the top of the
boot literally almost touches the bottom
about three Ines in like that's just
weird folks you know say what you want
uh and there's those oh I can't believe
you'd criticize them for for wearing Bo
no no no I'm criticizing that mentality
it's that insecurity Jesus if you're
that insecure just if you're five seven
whatever he is like own it right that
insecurity on a world stage is not GNA
work out well for us that's is he
talking about Ronda Sanchez she talking
about his dad I can't tell her what I
will say is what I will say
sometimes Don Jr makes a point okay he
makes a valid point broken clock is
right twice a day I mean the insecurity
of the Republican Party Maga you know oh
man I got to be big I gotta be Alpha I
gotta be tall I gotta be strong I Gotta
Be This I Gotta Be You know homerotic
whatever it might be uh the Republican
party is is someone who is so easily
triggered and so sensitive and so incure
for the very things that they attack
other people for being that's why you
find so many many these people who say
oh man look at all those groomers and
those gay people and this and that and
pedophilia and then you're like oh are
you guys are talking about yourselves oh
you're just talking about you're talking
about the aid from your team you're
talking about okay got it you're just
admitting you're confessing here well
here's here's Ronda sers before you go
to your show because you got to get over
there and get going here's Ronda santis
apparently a diagram of how he stands in
his boots or how people are thinking he
stands in his boots you posted this on
on Twitter is this is this real or is
this AI yeah this is no this is a this
is x-ray vision we were able to get a a
glance at Ronda San's shoes inside his
boots inside his pants just to give you
an idea of what kind of [__]
this [__] is going on this is like um um
Superman type Vision you know like youd
have on the super oh okay yeah yeah yeah
where you could see through the clothes
it it like the way in which he walks on
his heels like I I went to high school
with a guy who had a short Achilles
tendon and so he always walked on his
toes like the front half of his foot
right right because he couldn't fully
extend all the way down on the ground
for his heel Ronda santis is doing it
just out of insecurity this other guy
had a medical situation that he could
not do walk oh oh now I'm gonna tell you
I think this is medical right here this
is a mental illness that that Rhonda s
say it's definitely a medical this is I
mean it's it's not a physical illness
it's a some some might say some might
say that he could be excused from
getting the co 19 vaccine for said
medical
condition it could be could be Gabe
Sanchez Gabe Sanchez what was that live
right after this on YouTube and twitch
don't go anywhere if you're on YouTube
and twitch and if you're on Facebook go
go over to YouTube go over to Twitch and
tell Gabe Sanchez to open up a Facebook
account quit quit quit discriminating
against those goddamn Facebook users
Gabe Sanchez you been I'm not here to do
the Facebook have you have you been
getting those comments cuz I've been
telling them to comment get a Facebook
no I haven't seen any comments what in
the [__] proba because I filter out
Facebook I'm just kid I'm just kidding
you can't even type in Facebook on what
was go over there go do go do your go do
your show go do your show gab Sanchez
what was that live directly after the
Tony Michaels podcast here on YouTube
and on Twitch I am so glad you joined us
here today uh for all the Goofy and the
commentary as as usual and I want to
thank everyone who's put in orders for
the Tony Michaels podcast tattoo Merch
this machine kills fascist here's a
couple different views of the merch
there there's a couple different hoodies
there's t-shirts I'll be starting uh to
send out some social media post with the
different products on there just go to
the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com here's how you get to the
merch store there you just go to the
Tony michaels.com pan down the tattoo
merch merch collection is right here on
the Tony michaels.com I appreciate
everyone who has ordered their merch
also don't forget even my dog hates Ted
Cruz uh we're gonna do some different
variations of this we have to uh looks
like Josh Hol is gonna be up next even
my dog hates Ted Cruz if you want to
grab your even my dog hates Ted merch
just pan on down the Tony michaels.com
the link is here it'll take you to even
my dog hates Ted Cruz merch I appreciate
all your support there's been several
people sending in shots you know tonight
is Wednesday it's karaoke night so I'll
be doing karaoke and doing shots if you
want to send a venmo super chat in I'll
try to get it in on the screen uh for
you during the show Even if you send
them in overnight I'll try to get them
on the screen the very next day and if
you swear as much as me put some in the
swear jar and also I'll encourage you to
go follow me on patreon for free I've
got all those new articles there as well
and then go join the book club on
Discord they're going to be talking
about the obstacle is the way by Ryan
holiday that is the first book they'll
be reading and they're also going to
have conversations about Rachel mat's
audiobook they'll play the audio book in
the book club section of Discord and
have conversations with all your
favorite fuckum faman members so don't
forget to go join the book club it's
absolutely free to join the book club
and you can have those conversations in
the book club uh on Discord for free so
thank you very much don't forget same
time same place tomorrow Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube
Facebook and twitch Gabe Sanchez what
was that live on right after this on
YouTube and
twitch same time same place tomorrow
Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking